but now i'll be honest scott disick and
amelia hamlin
are instagram official the lord himself
took to his instagram stories on
saturday posting these two photos of he
and amelia out to dinner
the 37 year old reality star wrote on
one pick
why so serious followed by this sweet
photo with the caption quote
just kidding i'll be doing a
motivational speech on the
street later the couple was later
spotted on a romantic valentine's day
stroll on sunday
walking hand in hand on miami beach
scott showing off his newly bleached
hair
the announcement follows months of
sightings of scott and emilia together
the party has started we are here
the pair previously rang in the new year
while in mexico
and in january a source told e.t the
vacation was quote
a nice way for the both of them to
unwind relax and spend more time with
each other
amelia is easy going and gets along with
scott's friends
so they're able to just kick back and
have a good time
the source added amelia has also been
loving the attention
she's getting from being with scott
g goodbye and they're not the only new
couple celebrating the romantic holiday
scott's ex kourtney kardashian also has
a new boo
court and blink 182 drummer travis
barker seemingly implied they spent
their first valentine's day together
i'm just like living life and whatever
happens happens
the pair both shared this fireside image
to their instagram stories
with the 41 year old reality star adding
a heart emoji
and she even posted this loving poem
about her rocker boyfriend
that read quote roses are red violets
are blue
garlic bread blink 182 et learned in
january how scott feels about courtney's
new relationship
yeah what is happening here according to
a source it's always
a bit of an adjustment when one of them
is dating someone new
but at the end of the day he obviously
wants courtney to be happy
and they're focused on co-parenting
together
and as courtney and scott both move on
they just want you to know what they
really appreciate you guys teach
everyone the final season of keeping up
with the kardashians will premiere
march 18th i came over here in the
morning
a few days ago and i saw courtney and
scott asleep together on the couch
this sneak peek shows that some members
of the family think court and scott
should give it one last try he was here
and she was here they weren't far away
though
do we think they're like hooking up
again i just want them to try
i don't know maybe i mean scott's single
right now
if he fully moves on like has a baby
does that she's going to freak out
i think they're afraid that they're
going to like mess up their good
co-parenting
which could be an op option but you're
not one to talk
i'm not one to talk